Hello, everybody. We're going to talk about oxygenating tumors. It was, we always say an oxygenated
tumor is a happy tumor or maybe better term that oxygenated tumors is a sad tumor because it's
going to be a dying tumor. So if we can oxygenate cancers, the chance that we can help kill that cancer
is going to be better because cancer tends to thrive in a hypoxic environment. We've talked a
lot about the metabolism of that and how it uses lactic acid through glycolysis in a hypoxic
environment. That's how cancer tends to grow. So if we can oxygenate cancer, it can be better.
And we've had some videos that I've done on exercise. We'll talk a little bit about that
tonight. How do we oxygenate a tumor? So I broke it down in a few different steps here. Number one,
is simple exercise therapy. So if we are exercising in a way that's not causing hypoxia. So
whenever we talked about in our exercise video, we don't want to exercise to the point that we're
just completely exhausted ourselves and we're creating hypoxic areas in tissue because we're
expanding all our oxygen and muscle contraction. So there is a balance in exercise that we want to
exercise to the point that we increase circulation and we increase oxygenation. But we're not utilizing
all that oxygen because we're we're we're fatigued ourselves to the point because we're trying to
build muscle or run a marathon. So I'm not an advocate of trying to do marathon running while
you're dealing with a cancer. I think you're better off oxygenating your tumor through a good mild
exercise, lifting weights, calisthenics, using barbells, dumbbells, very good exercise. So you're
not creating this hypoxic environment again because you're fatigued yourself out. So exercise to
the point of you're utilizing your muscles, you're keeping muscle toned, you're huffing and puffing
a little bit but not completely fatigued out. So that's simple exercise therapy and that will help
oxygenate tumor because it's increasing circulated oxygen because you have that
increased called for oxygen. You're breathing heavily and you're getting some exercise increasing
oxygen. The second is what is called e-watt therapy. E-watt is short for exercise with oxygen therapy
and we really have to separate e-watt therapy into two different types. This would be called
simple e-watt therapy. So they're using an oxygen concentrator here. So this is an oxygen concentrator.
Typically, this oxygen concentrator is typically goes up to five liters of oxygen. There's some bigger
ones that go up to 10. Some that go up a little higher but this particular brand here is probably five
liters and this person has an oxygen mask on and they're doing some sort of exercise. The exercise
is regardless of what type of exercise you choose. So you could go on a treadmill and do this. We used
to do a lot of e-watt therapy in our office. We had several treadmills. We had several stair
steppers. I think at one time at six or seven of these little oxygen concentrators in our office,
people had their own cannula and their own face mask. We keep them in a file for them and people
would come in. This is when we saw a lot of local people for brain-based therapy. So this is a big
piece of our brain-based therapy program for people with any kind of early dementia, kids with any type of
EDD, ADHD, people with fibromyalgia, Lyme patients, exercise with oxygen therapy, increases the blood
oxygen faster than using just regular exercise. So this would be considered maybe a step up from regular
exercise because you have a concentration of oxygen that you're breathing in. The next form of
exercise with oxygen therapy came out just a few years ago. It's called LIVO2 and this
uses oxygen concentrator that's a little bit stronger oxygen concentrator and fills this bag. So it's
this great big oxygen reservoir that's on this stand here. It's a great big giant bag. This is filled
up first and that you are doing the same thing. They're showing these people on bicycles but it could
be a treadmill. It could be a stair stepper. They could use multiple oxygen concentrators in
Uticent to give a greater concentration of oxygen that that person's building that breathing in.
This is more of an advanced exercise with oxygen therapy and research has shown that it works better
than a simple version like this. So this would be the next step up. Really when you talk about
oxygenating tumors though, all the studies on oxygenate tumors are not with EWAT therapy. The studies
on oxygenate tumors are with hyperbaric therapy. There's a big difference. There's a big step between
EWAT and hyperbaric. I would say EWAT could a person with cancer use EWAT? Why sure? If you have access
to an EWAT system like a libo2 or even oxygen concentrator using it with some sort of exercise,
go for it. That's probably better than simple exercise. The problem with that is this kind of
clumsy and it's not really comfortable. Whereas we're just getting out and getting some regular
exercise and getting outside doing that. Getting out with friends doing that has some advantages. You
have to think of what you're going to stick with also. But far greater in oxygen concentration to
the tumor itself is the hyperbaric therapy. So hyperbaric therapy is what all the studies have
been done with. Now I know there's been some studies that have shown that hyperbaric therapy hasn't
really helped certain cancers. Most of them that have come out that are independent studies
have shown good help with cancer. The problem with hyperbaric is the same problem with any of the other
oxygenation techniques, be exercise or anything, is that you've got to stick to it on a regular basis.
We have this hyperbaric chamber in our office. Why did you do it on me when I was there for two days?
Because if you're not going to do it on a regular basis, two days of doing hyperbaric oxygen,
it really isn't going to make any difference in a person's life. So we want to do something that's
going to make a difference in your life and doing two days of it is not going to be that thing.
This one here is a 23-inch diameter tube. This is a home unit that Oxi Health makes and we actually
have the ability to get a rental program for people if they want to do that. It's kind of pricey
and I think it's about $2,000 a month or something like that or $1,500 a month. But it is,
it's a nice unit to have in your home. Believe it or not, a lot of people use these in their home,
especially lying patients or people with any concussion issues. It's really big in the football
industry right now. Professional football players are buying these like crazy and using these to
protect their brain after workouts and after games. This is something they can travel with in a hotel
room. It packs up into a big type thing about the size of a massage table and it's fairly easy to
use. This isn't the whole of it. It's connected. You can see this piece. You can connect it to an
oxygen concentrator or you're just connected to the pressurization take that pressurizes it.
This is what really, again, all the studies are on for cancer patients. It improving the lives of
cancer patients and survival and oxygenation tumors. How often would you do this? It's recommended
daily for an hour, five days a week. You have to either have it in your house or have a
clinic near you that you could go in and do this. We have some local patients that come in to do
hyperbaric. Are we getting success with them? Yes. Is it because of the hyperbaric? I have no idea.
That's not the only thing that they're doing. They're doing other therapies while they're here. They're
doing the right way. Everything else you guys are doing at home. It's very hard to quantify what's
the cause of the person's success in their treatment of their cancer or other disease when they're
doing multiple things. That's a question that somebody had about exercise with oxygen. Would I
recommend it? Yes, but I'd start with simple exercise. This is a way to go. These things are relatively
inexpensive. You could probably buy them used for a few hundred dollars. These units are a couple
thousand dollars. I doubt if you'll find them used. They're fairly new on the market. Then a full
unit like this is 25,000 but a full unit like this might be 12,000 and you could rent them for less than
a couple thousand dollars a month. That's the difference in price. Exercise like this is great.
Buy a set of dumbbells and you can do this on your own. This has some benefits. Simple exercise has
benefits over EWAT and over hyperbaric in that you're doing hyperbaric. You're not increasing muscle
tone. You're doing EWAT. The only thing you're increasing muscle tone because it's almost always a
lower body exercise. If you have any knee problems or hip problems, you can't do this.
You can choose what exercise you're doing to help increase muscle tone, which is really
improvement and important especially with the kexia issues that we've talked about on some other
videos too. Okay, so I am going to unmute everybody. We're getting feedback here. Any question
This is Carolyn Wisconsin. Does a person go in that thing or how does that work?
So the hyperbaric, are you talking about this thing here?
The other ones, the football players use. Yeah, you go in this. So this unzips and you climb in there
and lay down and you feel so this, the negative of this is it's not for people who have claustrophobia.
And that can be an issue. It's not for people who have sinus issues. I can't go in it.
It's but it is you go in there and you feel like you have to pop your ears and maybe choose some gum
for the first couple minutes and then you don't notice anything. You can lie in there and read a book.
You can lie in there and use your computer. You can use your iPad. You can listen to music.
There isn't anything electrical in there that would interfere with anything electrical that you have on your
body. It's great for people that you know are not really horribly ambulatory. They can get around
very well. They can climb in there and take a nap. That's what a lot of the football players that I
know do. They just get in there and they just go in there and take an nap for an hour and they do this
an hour a day. It's extremely beneficial for your pain. I have a friend who's a doctor who had a
patient who had Alzheimer's where he couldn't remember his kids names and his grandkids names.
His wife was freaking out. They bought a chamber. Actually, I think it was this one right here that
they bought for their home within a week. The wife called his doctor who I know and said,
you will not believe my husband. He's like a different person. He's overplayed ping pong with the
grandkids right now. So make a giant difference for your brain and dementia issues and Alzheimer's
issues. That's probably the biggest use of it right now is with post-compulsive disorder
and any kind of brain fog because it could make a big difference pretty quick.
Okay, thank you. Dr. Connors? Yes. A different subject, but goat's milk. I'm not supposed to be on
cow's milk, but I'm really having a craving for milk. Is goat's milk an alternative if I just
don't go overboard or just completely stay away from dairy? So there's reasons why a person will be
off of dairy would be they have a sensitivity to lactose, the sugar in the dairy. That's not why we
have you off dairy. Second reason, person will be off dairy is they have a sensitivity to
case seed, the protein in dairy. That's not why we have you off dairy. We have you off dairy because
dairy stimulates, emptores, stimulates the caros pathway, stimulates growth, stimulates growth, hormone
pathways, and goat's milk does the same as cow's milk. So if a person has, there's people that
will have a sensitivity to dairy. That's why they're off dairy and they may not be sensitive to the same
case seed goat's milk, but that's not you. So goat will still stimulate growth pathways. So
that's where we push people towards trying to use the nut milks, the coconut milk, the coconut
almond mixture. That's what I use. But yeah, so again, everything is within moderation. You're just
going to have a little bit of goat's milk. It's a balance of light, really. So
you've got to define what moderation I guess is, but yeah. All right. Thanks. Any other questions?
All right. Well, thank you everybody for being on. Make sure that you email any questions that you
have. And please continue to utilize the Facebook page posting anything and post yummy recipes on
there that you might want to share with other people and any positive feedback that you can give
to share with other people as well. We try to keep that a very positive experience for everybody.
So I will see you next week. Bye bye everybody.